hello my name is David Cone injur I'm a
director of R&D at Thermo Fisher
Scientific within our cell biology
business and it's really my pleasure to
share with you some descriptions and
applications of our relatively new get
Cobie 27 plus culture system and
specifically it's used in both stem cell
and primary cell applications so I
thought I would start with outline of
the presentation I'm going to give a
very brief history on the b27 supplement
and going into an overview of the new
system and then really the bulk of the
presentation is going to focus on the
applications benefits values of the new
system in neuronal applications I know
this is for our 24 hours of stem cells
presentation or meaning but I thought
it'd be useful to include some data on
primary neurons also I think just for
for broader context as well as I know
many many laboratories will use both PSC
stem cell derived and primary rodent
models for for parallel types of studies
and then I'll end with a brief summary
so a 1 1 1 slide history of the b27
supplement this was invented over 20
years ago by a Greg brewer and was
subsequently commercialized as the first
serum-free a supplement for neuronal
cell culture it was originally developed
to help maintain ex vivo cultures of
primary rodent neurons and and tissue ex
plants and it's been you know since then
highly used thousands and thousands of
citations and it's really sort of a core
reagent for for neuronal neural
neurobiology research and and more
recently transiting into numerous and
relatively broad applications in stem
cell differentiation systems um
one fun fact debbie 27-minute name is
derived from the be is from brewer last
name of the inventor and it was actually
his 27th iteration of the formulation so
so that's where the name comes from and
then you know over time as i mentioned
as the field has evolved applications
have become more diverse more
sophisticated in many ways
the you know the use of this supplement
has grown but but also leading you know
it's the broader applications have
required additional modification
supplementation's tweaks to get it to
work for these sort of new and maybe
outside of the original focus of the
media and as we've been manufacturing
this over the years and have developed a
few sort of variants of it you know
we've gotten a lot of feedback we've had
a lot of understanding or gained more
insight into that kind of the
shortcomings are really the the growing
needs and applications and maybe where
the the classic version of the
supplements all was was coming up short
and so this was really the rationale
that led us into the development of the
b27
formulation so this slide is introducing
the the culture system so it's it's
quite severe familiar with the classic
beat 27 and neuro Basel combination this
is going to look very familiar
the new system is B 27 plus supplement
which is a 50 X that comes typically our
standard in an attempt n ml of volume
and neuro basal plus medium in a sort of
standard 500 ml pack size and together
these added together this creates the
the B 27 plus normal culture system and
all should be using that that this term
throughout the throughout the rest of
the talk so so really you know what's
changed surprisingly we made relatively
modest formulation changes formulation
and manufacturing changes that had a
surprisingly big impact on performance
and and so you know the formula the
formulation was optimized once in
relatively small ways of course was
proprietary but you know we did not add
additional small molecules or growth
factors so no exotic components were
added and and the manufacturing for so
so we did modify how we actually make
this which which can have substantial
impact on consistency and performance we
tightened up criteria for several of the
key raw materials that goes that goes
into the the product the finish good as
well as more stringent QC release
testing so again relatively modest
changes minor changes in the formulation
and I think had a surprisingly big
impact and we'll we'll get into that in
the subsequent slides so again first I'm
going to go through the primary neuron
data it's going to be structured quite
similarly to to how I'm going to walk
through the the PSE or stem cell derived
data but but again I think contextually
I think it was useful to include um even
in a stem cell focused conference
okay so this slide illustrates really
the the key benefit that we see in both
the stem cell derived models sorry both
the primary cell and stem cell derived
models and that's essentially we we see
consistently a greater viability higher
greater viability and higher quality
neurons you know over time and so this
is this these two photomicrographs this
is a primary rat cortical neurons at
three weeks those cultured in the B 27
plus has indicated on the low sorry at
the plus is indicated on the right or
the classic b27 system on the left the
green is mapped to staining blue is
Hoechst died or Dappy and the the red
staining or purple Co staining is for a
neural marker hue cqd and so what's very
apparent on these images that in the
right you have both more neurons they
have more extensive neurite networks and
branching this is really something we
consistently see across all the neural
models that we're looking at and there
are also think substantial downstream
benefits with respect to maturation cell
health and performance in terms of
electrophysiological activities which
we'll discuss in more detail
so again looking just you know a crime
course here we're looking at rat
cortical neurons again the top row is
showing cells again these are immune
acetic chemical images each column is a
different week as indicated at the top
of the slide the top row is the classic
b27 or basal culture conditions and then
below is our new plus system so again
this one can see you know we see these
benefits early they start to really
manifest themselves and really become
quite distinguished in terms of cell
numbers and and extent of night a
branching you know within two weeks and
beyond
uh moving on similar results are seen
with you know with other rodent species
so in this case we're looking at Mouse
cortical neurons you can see again the
b27
a column to the left the b27
plus column just to the right of that a
similar types of staining here so so
we're looking at map to to see QD as a
neural marker this the staining for CC
QD is more restricted to the cell body
area and this makes the image analysis
and automated automated image analysis
and capture at quantitation much more
straightforward for us so many of the
subsequent fields were our slides that
will show a quantitation of neural
counts are going to be based on the QC
QD data but we have very high
concordance with wit map two staining
it's just sort of easier to count the
cell bodies than the extended processes
below both of the ICC images are based
contrast images of the equivalent fields
and then to the right as the
quantitation the hue CCD quantitation of
the neural cell numbers at three weeks
so again much like the rat data I should
previously we have really substantial
increases in viability significant
increases in viability over time in the
in the mouse model also one of the
consequences of this that we find is
also a key benefit is the because of the
the higher cell survival with the plus
system you're able to use a seed fewer
numbers of cells so particularly if your
cell source is a limited or if you're
purchasing them commercially this can
really be an added benefit you can you
know increase your n a test a different
number of conditions just get get more
more bang for for your for your limited
cell numbers if you will
walking away from just the sort of gross
cell number data and then looking a
little deeper in terms of maturation and
performance so in this case we're
looking at a comparison of this is the
rat cortical neurons and we're looking
at a quantifying neurite outgrowth over
time so in the upper phase so the upper
images you have this these are false
colored images that are quantifying
generated from SN Biosciences in a
keysight zoom platform where we're doing
a live cell analysis of night length the
false coloring is so the cell bodies are
in yellow the b27 classic cells are on
the left and those incubated in the b27
plus system are on the right the
neurites are marked in this case by the
purple extensions and that's actually
what the software is quantifying in
these in these live cell images and what
you see below them is the the mean right
length or average night length from from
the data set that's that's represented
above so much like the increase in cell
number that we saw we actually see an
increase in the extent and rate of
aneroid extension and this is an
indicator of cell health and relative
maturation state
if we look again at a different set of
markers and this is going to be looking
at pre and postsynaptic markers in rat
cortical neurons we see a kind of a
similar overall trend in this case we're
looking at day 28 these are these are
fixed cells and stained with either in
the top row markers for looking at the
presynaptic structures so in this case
sort of a pan synapse and antibody
excuse me that's shown in green so on
the upper upper left you have cells that
have been cultured in the same lot of
cells actually of course throughout this
whole all these panels that were
cultured in the b27
classic system or in the plus system on
the upper right clearly you can see a
substantial difference in the extent of
synapse and expression as indicated in
green these also decorate the NA rights
and axonal bodies much more clearly in
the plus system and then if we look at
the bottom the bottom row we're looking
at staining in this case in green for
PSD 95 this is a postsynaptic marker and
again much like we saw above we have in
in the B 27 plus conditions a much
higher expression of PSD 95 and much
more targeted localization within the
within the axons themselves that and so
again these are consistent with increase
in maturation of the the neurons that
have been cultured in the B 27 plus
system
and then one other thing we looked at
here and when we were curious about as
you probably can appreciate that these
the cultures that the primary rodent and
neural neural cultures are not really
pure there are actually mixtures of
different cell types so they're
different types of neurons because there
as well as glial cells as well as other
cell types and so so we were very
curious about what types of neurons are
being you know maintained over time
in these two culture systems so in this
case we've started with again the single
lot of rat cortical neurons we're
staining at day 28 with cells that have
been cultured in either the b27
classic or b 27 plus system and so if we
look at the the left half that the lower
images the lower set of images we're
looking at so actually we're trying to
tease out what the relative population
of the excitatory inhibitory neurons are
within these within these rat cortical
cultures in incubated or maintained
under the two different media conditions
and so we're looking at on the lower
left the two panels we're looking at
expression of v glute which is a marker
for glutamatergic or excitatory neurons
and we see relatively similar ratios of
these when we do the salome equality
Shanor high-content analysis of these
and then if we're moving up to the upper
right we're going to look at we're
looking at staining for inhibitory
neurons or a class of inhibitory neurons
so the GABA positive or GABAergic
neurons and again we see even though we
see more total cells in the B 27 plus
conditions as we consistently see this
if we look at just the relative ratio of
cells they're quite similar to for the
GABAergic we see if we count these we
see approximately 12% of the cells that
are GABA positive in the classic and 14
percent in the plus system and where we
see a real
divergence is is when we're looking at a
subtype of the GABAergic neurons these
are parvalbumin or pv+
inter neurons and we saw a really a
rather dramatic difference here we saw
less than 1% of the cells that were
maintained in the b27 a classic system
or pv+ where we had about 7% of the
cells in the b27 plus system were pv+
so you know why is this important or
interesting to us we think the pv inter
neurons are very interesting population
of cells and they've been reported to
play a really an important regulatory
function in controlling the activity or
synchrony between these networks of
excitatory and inhibitory neurons so so
maintaining sort of appropriate Network
networked activity and I think this may
come into play with some of the later
slide so I'm going to show okay so so
moving into activity of the cells so a
little bit of a primer on the multi
electrode array system so this is
basically a plate based analysis method
to assess electrical activity of of
different cell types so I've seen
neurons and a cardiomyocytes or another
cell model that are that are widely used
on this platform the image on the the
left side is the photo micrograph of in
this case showing the array bed as well
mouse mouse cortical neurons which are a
little bit hard to see here sitting on
top of in this case the 16 electrodes
and the electrodes themselves so this
these electrodes are embedded in the
bottom of in this case it's a 24 well
plate and so the little balls on the end
of the the lines are actually the
physically the electrodes themselves and
so these electrodes can can sense
electrical activity in the cells that
are in proximity to them and so we've
used this and in this case we're using
the acción Biosystems maestro pro
platform to do all of our MEA
measurements and what the graph on the
right
showing is just a mean firing rate so so
essentially we're looking at just
spontaneous activity as measured on each
of those little the 16 sensors in the in
the embedded in the array well over time
and so and across different culture
systems and so what you can see is the
activity starting from you know day 5
out to day 35 is the activity increases
and what we have 3 different media
conditions are B 27 plus in the dark
blue the classic be 27 and kind of the
intermediate blue and then this is a
competitor media this is the SMM one
brain says system and and what we see is
that initially the SM one brain fizz
system shows pretty robust activity but
this tends to trail off by approximately
three weeks and whereas the B 27 plus
activity is really maintained increases
steadily over time and plateaus and
actually gives you a large assay window
that's really quite robust over time
so moving
the next slide this is going to dig into
the array data a little bit more
utilizing different parameters that one
can tease out of this spontaneous
activity and so I've shown to two images
on the left here but these are actually
from accion's website were they to help
identify and to to visualize the type of
data and the type of calculations that
can be done and then how you translate
that back to the biology that you're
studying so essentially if you think of
this as this horizontal line with these
little vertical hashes these can be
these are indications of electrical
activity at at a given sensor and you
can see there's there's there can be
groups of them or these sort of
clustering of spikes the spikes have a
fixed duration that will have a
durations that can be measured the inter
burst intervals can be calculated as
well as the overall burst frequency so
that's for an individual electrode then
as is if you recall the previous slide I
showed that that array actually had 16
electrodes so we can actually measure
each of those electrodes simultaneously
and then and look at the activity
spatially so not only temporarily you
know over time but spatially in terms of
they're physically separated but but are
they electrically coupled and so what
we're looking at at the middle the
middle graphs here are really assessing
these are these are called raster plot
so we're looking at synchronous bursting
and in this case we're looking at day 28
rat cortical neurons these cells the
upper set of data is with the the the
neurons aware incubated or maintained in
the B 27 plus system the middle set in
the classic B 27 and then the lower set
this is in the brain says media again
this is all at the day 28 in culture day
28 and what you can clearly see is we
get a highly synchronous regular
bursting with the B 27 a plus system so
and this is the these traces are based
on the cow
deleted on the data that comes out
directly from from the 16 electrodes so
very very robust very consistent
electrical activity okay so I'm going to
that was kind of the primer of many of
the same approaches that were described
that I walked through with the primary
neurons will go through with the stem
cell derived neurons but but before we
get into the actual data I think it's
one thing to point out and something
that we've been we've been looking at
extensively is that you know there's
really a number of different ways to to
get at stem cell derived neurons there's
a number of different approaches to to
derive them and the figure on the left
is kind of our approach at illuminating
or highlighting those and and so really
so if you look at the upper route this
is sort of a random differentiation to
an Android body followed by plating and
having these neural rosette form and
which they spontaneously form and then
those can be picked you know isolated
manually picked and then expanded and
you know can provide a very robust and
reliable source of neural stem cells the
middle route would be again starting
from a pluripotent stem cell on the far
left and then using a more of a media
based we're calling the monolayer
approach and this is an example of this
is using our neural induction media
where you you basically stimulate or
drive using cold culture conditions
drive the formation of the NSCs
themselves with high efficiency and then
the the lower route this is what we're
terming the factor induced method and
this is really more of a genetic
approach where where one delivers an
over expresses a neurogenic regulatory
factor ngn to is an example of this
where you can add add these factors to
two pluripotent stem cells for example
induce certain sprat induce their
expression and they
you know they will push these cells to
general fate all three of these are
really commonly used they they have
different pluses and minuses and I
really won't get it and get into them
specifically but but what I will will
say is that we we thought it was
important to assess whether or not or
the impact of the b27 plus system in in
each of these different types of NFC to
to neuron models and and what I'm going
to sort of summarized a little bit on
the left is what we've seen over all is
that much like the data with the primary
neurons we've seen improve NarL health
and better long-term survival we see an
accelerated maturation as assess by by
Nora and outgrowth and and synaptic
marker expression and again improved
performance as assessed by MEA analysis
so just walking through that data in
this case we're looking at improved
long-term survival of neurons that were
derived from rosette NSCs so the the
images on the left will show just you
know these are fixed images of the
neurons so again Hugh cqd map - and
Dappy in blue again we're using the QC
QD expression to get the neural counts
very clear just from the images that
there are many more neurons with the b27
plus system excuse me those are as
quantitated to the graph on the right
and again this is survival at four weeks
so this is very much in line with what
we saw with the stem cell door at the
primary rodent neurons
similarly if we look at new right
outgrowth in in this case we're looking
at again this is another rosette derived
a human IPSC neuron model if we look at
the extent of neurite outgrowth over
time and cells that were incubated in
either the classic b27 system again the
pseudo color images from the from the
essence oome are shown on the left
versus the pseudo color images from the
cells cultured in the B 27 plus system
are shown on the right again increased
extent of neurites
we see the quantitation to the right so
so again it's an overall consistency in
performance to what we saw with the
primary neurons looking at this case at
synaptic marker expression and in this
model we're using the monolayer derived
NSCs and again we're showing the the
images on the upper left those are
cultured in the b27 classic or the B 27
plus we're looking at
synapse in oh you know I'm sorry these
colors these are actually mixed up
synapse and is shown in green map to is
in red this legend is mixed up apologize
for that but but what you can see is
that the the increase in the punctate
the green staining is much higher in the
synapse and I'm sorry in the B 27 plus
cultured cells the punctate stain is
exactly what you'd expect to see for
for-4 synapse and also we quantify when
we're quantifying that using our Salam X
cx-5 platform again we see much like you
can see visually when we Quantic
quantify this expression over time over
many fields and multiple wells we see
consistently in create consistent
increase in synapse and expression over
time and then if we look at activity and
so we're going to look at activity a
couple of different ways one one by just
mean at mean firing rate or average
average spikes or average activity per
time which is shown in the graph on the
left you can see comparing actually the
b27 plus system to the brain says as to
a competitor system not the classic b27
in this case and and with this data this
was actually done by by this was work
done by scientists at fulcrum
therapeutics who were looking at the
activity studying the activity of one of
their in-house IPS see neural models
that were that were generated by the
factor driven approach which is outlined
on the right and in this case they're
doing expression over expression of ng
and two in the first period and then
incubation with the various maturation
conditions so again a different model
but showing very consistent results in
terms of high highly active cultures
from maintenance and and maturation in
the b27 plus system and since the last
functional data this is looking across
these are the the similar raster plots
to what I showed earlier in this case
we're looking at a synchronous activity
bursting activity and monolayer or
neural induction NSCs that were derived
from the neural induction media and if
you look starting from the upper left
these ourselves in the B 27 plus system
the between some classic below that and
then to the right the the brain 2 system
so again we see much more synchronous
and regular bursting activity with the B
27 plus maintained NSCs and I would
point out that we were able to it's not
shown here this is day 31 that we're
looking at but we were able to maintain
the this highly networked activity for
for more than four additional weeks with
the B 27 plus system so was a fairly
stable assay window and this is
something I think we're continuing to
optimize I don't I don't think we've
completely nailed I think we can
actually get this to work substantially
better than we have thus far
okay and so really one of the last
things I wanted to just point out is you
know guidance for the use of the B 27
plus with the PSC derived neurons and
this is something we have you know we've
been appreciating more and more lately
and and and are providing I think where
hopefully is a specific and useful
guidance to to folks who are wanting to
use the system for the NSC direct models
and and really that that we're finding
that that the addition that timings
really the key for the use to get the
optimal performance using the B 27 plus
system with the PSC derived neurons and
so what we're and it's really what what
we think is going on is that the the
real the benefit of the system comes
after the NSCs are committed and so in
this case where they start to adopt this
neural neuro more
ecology they start to have these sort of
projections and you can start to really
distinguish the neurites they're
extending out and contacting neighboring
cells so the the images at the upper the
the upper phase contrast images are
really these are cells that are
approximately n SES that are have been
plated you know a is just like one day
in I think B is from two to two or three
days in and then C is this is day 5 or
day six and so once you the cells have
adopted this more extended branching
morphology it's really the ideal time to
switch to the B 27 plus system and
that's indicated in the schematic below
you know one other things as we've been
working with these various ways to
derive the NSE something also that's
really that's really become quite
apparent to us is the the requirements
the composition the media the growth
factor requirements for the neural
differentiation aspect to to to
basically induce neural differentiation
from from the the various entities can
can vary dramatically depending on the
derivation method of the NSCs so
basically some some types of entities
are much easier to get to form neurons
than others and so we think that we've
we in our hands this is a really
important optimization step we provided
some guidance on this at least some of
the sort of easier or harder ways or
some bigger or smaller hammers if you
will to sort of push the cells a.22
neuro neural maturation or commitment
and maturation in in our be 27 plus user
guide for first stem cells and this can
be found on our website you can to
search for B 27 plus and and you'll be
able to find that relatively easily okay
and so with that I'll just go to a
summary try to keep the summaries and I
type so really you know that our
summaries here are just general guidance
for using the products for primary
neurons or stem cell derived neurons and
and and which will hopefully enable you
to derive the benefits
I've highlighted in the prior slide so
for general guidance for our culture and
primary rodent neurons is basically just
switch wherever you were using b27
classic you can switch to be 27 plus you
will have what we find consistently as
higher-quality neurons you will have
more neurons over time so one of the one
aspect of this though is you may
actually want to or need to reduce
seating densities and because you're
going to end up with more neurons then
then you had initially with with the
classic as well as the addition of serum
or other components that might have been
required using the classic system may
not be required at all here so you may
be another way to potentially reduce
costs and variability
lastly the general guidance for the
using the be 27 plus for the stem cell
derived models is really just trying to
recoup or recapture what what I had
mentioned in some of the earlier slides
that but it's really timing is the
important part and that the switching
over to the B 27 plus system after you
have committed neurons is really what
what we have found to be the key to
success and and that this seems to
translate across multiple derivation
methods in terms of how one could
generate NSCs and with that I will thank
you for your time and I hope you found
this valuable and think we'll end it
there Thanks